The racers were ready at dawn.
Very tense.
In some circles, King
of the Hammers is a far
far better thing than the
Super Bowl, the Kentucky Derby
and a Kim Kardashian NFT
drop, all rolled into one.
This race attracts a very special breed.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Piss off.
It was time to get grounded
to ponder this rotten assignment
and figure out how to cope with it.
Seven days in the deep desert surrounded
by madness and anarchy.
King of Hammers.
It's race day you all.
Hell, even the grandmas here
make Burning Man look
like a bunch of grandmas.
Those of us who had been up all night were
in no mood for lattes and sausage rolls.
We wanted strong drink.
We were after all the absolute cream
of internet travel log influencers.
We were gathered here in the
desert of Johnson Valley,
California to witness
the spirit of invention
in its most feral form.
When it comes to a thing like this,
you don't fool around.
The man driving this beast of
a vehicle is Shannon Campbell.
He's 53, has very poor vision
and has won King of the
Hammers, three times.
He's an absolute racing legend.
And you're about to see why.
Look at Shannon.
A complete roll lands on the tires and
keeps on going.
You or I might be traumatized
by a near death experience like that,
but not Shannon.
Had a good run going up on top
and I stuffed it and it kicked
the fuel pump out or something.
What about when you flipped?
That was crazy.
I screwed up, I was,
Oh, is that scary though? It's got to be.
No, I mean, scary is when it doesn't
get landed on its wheels.
Things you should know about
King of the Hammers.
It's a 10 day event that takes place
in the Southern California desert.
There are a series of races
for different types of off-road vehicles.
Also, mayhem, chaos and very few rules.
Totally normal thing to do.
This year, 80,000 maniacs attended.
Revelries commence with the time trials
and climax with the Race of Kings.
A 200 mile course that requires
drivers to conquer rocks
and to drive at incredibly
high speeds across the desert.
It's basically impossible.
So it attracts the kind of
people who like impossible.
People like Bailey Campbell, who headed
into race week as a serious
contender for the Crown.
I got my whole family out here.
My dad, my brother, my husband.
How many years have you done this?
This will be my eighth King of the Hammers
Eighth. Okay.
The Campbell's are a racing family.
There's Bailey's brother Wayland.
And you've already met Dad, Shannon
and she married a fellow
speed fiend as well.
Is that your husband, back from the track?
Yeah.
Money.
It was so smooth.
I got it by six seconds.
Oh
We watched it, yeah.
For Bailey though things
aren't going so smoothly
with only a few precious
days before the big race,
Bailey has just found out
that her vehicle is in need of big fixes.
I mean I know vehicles are
always kind of fickle and every
this is normal or,
Probably, no, no.
It's not.
Nope, this probably
the worst repair we've had to do all year.
Yeah.
I will call you later tonight
when you guys are ready
to go through UTB parts
to disperse through pits.
You're going to run home, try to fix it
and then try to get back by Friday.
Yeah. Yeah.
Wish you a lot of luck.
Get back here.
Thank you.
Okay, thanks.
And just like that, Bailey is wondering
if she'll even be able to race.
A lot of the competitors are
like her, passionate, scrappy,
barely holding their cars together.
Then there are folks like Jason Scherer.
We have enough ground
clearance to literally
get our tire between this rock,
and this.
Jason is one of this year's favorites.
Like Shannon, he's won King
of the Hammers three times.
75% of people don't finish this race.
Finishing it's an monumental task,
And an achievement.
Right? And you feel good after if
you do it, but once you've won it,
finishing it is no longer the goal,
it's only winning it again.
If the Campbells are a DIY family affair,
Jason is a polished professional
with money, a big team,
and a decked out vehicle.
I was wonder if we could geek
out a little bit on the car.
Well this car was a fun one to build.
So I spent the last two and
a half years designing it
on a computer before we ever
started cutting the first tube.
This thing really does have it all.
An engine with enough horsepower to top
150 miles per hour on
the desert straightaways,
shocks that can basically
see what's coming
before it hits you.
A hardened underbelly to make sure rocks
don't shoot up into a
fuel tank or your thigh,
and Lidar and GPS to help
find that perfect route
through the rocks.
So as you can see, it says
Big Rock on the GPS right now,
which is basically
describes the whole place.
Still, even with all
the bells and whistles
Jason has to put his
body through this race,
like everybody else.
What the is a LiDar when you're in the,
I mean it looks insane, you know.
It's full punk rock.
It is brutal.
It is, it is a pounding.
I would get my kidneys to bleed.
I would get blood in my
mouth while we were driving
and feel it when I started
and I didn't think I
was driving hard enough
unless I had that feeling.
What Jason is describing is the law of
Internal organs, which says,
they tend to stay in motion
even after your body has slammed
into rocks at high speeds.
And that's just the physical part.
Ooh, I love it!
Oh, I love it.
God, it's so hard to do.
Ah, ah.
Wasn't I like crying in there?
You might be
Ah, that's embarrassing.
S-t.
I thought it was touching, man.
Man, that was funny though.
One thing's for sure, it's
a hell of a rush, man.
I need one more.
I need to know that I was the best here,
and if I never finish another one
but I got one more win,
I'll be totally content
And nobody's won four.
Nobody's won four.
Right, yeah.
I want to be the first one.
Hang around these guys long enough,
and you too will start to feel the itch.
Time to get my organs shook.
Where did this go?
Right there.
All right, here we go.
That is crazy, man.
That's what I came here for.
It makes no sense.
It was awesome.
It doesn't make any sense man.
What? Like, like it's fun.
It's but why would anyone do this?
I was shaken, rattled and delirious.
Just to say, can we do it again?
I have good news.
We have found the spot
where dreams come true.
Now, you know.
After the time trials, the teams regroup
do some work on their cars
and make their plans for the big race.
Since I tragically did not
have a car of my own to fix
it was time to explore.
This is Hammer Town, where most
of the onlookers stay.
About a 10 minute drive away,
just outside of the thick of things,
there is Lasertown.
It's where the, the riff
raff who want to get away
from the riff raff come spend the week.
There are people who
like King of the Hammers,
and then there's Cody
who loves it so much,
he decided to build his own private oasis.
We actually have 40 acres now.
Right next to the race.
We are having a large fire,
Friday night and Saturday night.
So, if you guys are
around, or if you're not
you can probably see it from anywhere.
But don't call the authorities
if you see a structure fire.
'cause it's probably us.
It has everything a man in no man's land
could want.
Art.
First. You got to play
with them a little bit.
A koi pond
That's Sunny, he's a pig.
And of course a luxurious home made
out of shipping containers.
That's not what I expected.
That's the point.
There's even room for
a couple hundred close friends.
It's kind of turned into a
campground, we'll call it.
Yeah, and, uh,
Do you feel like, feed all these people
or do they fend for themselves?
No, they fend for themselves.
They just, they, I just provide the dirt.
They might be building cities from scratch
these days, but to hear an
OG like Shannon tell it,
things were very different
when the race first
started back in 2007.
I mean we started out
way back in the day, just
rock crawling for fun.
You know, friends going out
and hill climbing, and you know
back then there was a whole
lot of alcohol and fun
involved, but,
This event has grown so much
from when there was a few
of you guys around a fire, you know
doing your own thing to now 80,000 people.
That was,
That was the good days when
it was just very simple
and you know, you weren't out here for
you'd show up for a couple of days
for this race and now we're
here for two weeks and,
I don't know how long you've been here
but I'm ready to get the hell out of here.
Right. Breathing dirt
Sitting there the day
before the main event,
Sipping a Bloody Mary
made by Bloody Mary Larry.
Bloody Mary.
Oh yeah, Bloody Mary Larry makes the best.
Thank you Larry.
Shannon's mind was on
his daughter and her car.
She's tough, she'll get over
it, but I mean it kills her
'cause she's literally been working
on her car since the last race.
Just, I mean, polishing
it, looking everything over
you know, just anything she
can do to make it better
and be perfect when she got here.
And then you know, it doesn't
take anything to take you out.
You know, it's, and we haven't
even got to the race yet.
With the race approaching, it was time to
meet some more contenders.
I'm sometimes PG.
I'll try to keep it PG Thursday.
You don't have to.
You can do whatever you want.
Oh, we do it all.
Oh, all right.
The Gomez brothers are one
of those teams that
make other racers sweat.
There's Marcos, JP and
last year's winner, Raul.
They operate a booming
tree clearing business
in Northern California
and funnel a portion
of their good fortune into
this ridiculous hobby.
And all in for this
whatever week, 10 days,
between the vehicles and the
team and just the living stuff.
I mean how much do you
think it costs to be here
for this race?
So if you went to buy a car like this?
You're spending 350,000, $400,000.
350,000,
400.000.
Just to like buy one.
Just to buy the car.
Okay.
The tire's $1,200.
Yeah.
The wheel's $900
And it, it just adds up.
And, you're spending 500,000.
To come do this thing.
Yeah. Yeah.
Give it a go, Cool.
A real competitive go.
Yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
There's a little difference.
If you want to come out, trail
ride around and get ran over,
that's a different story.
Just look for a car, 86. That's me.
Marcos Gomez for the,
I'll be on the podium tomorrow.
Thanks.
Spoiler alert.
This is not how it played
out for Marcos, but his brother Raul,
well, we'll get there.
Oh no.
As with any town in America,
there's life during the day.
Oh, I really am bad dude, Jesus.
And then, there's what comes after.
What do you guys do at night?
Go up to chocolate, back door,
watch the rock crawlers and the carnage.
Just hang out?
Yeah, drink beers and hang out.
Yeah.
It's, human Mario Kart.
That's what it is.
Where are we?
We're on like Thursday of this thing.
Every night's like a different party.
This one is in the place
they call the back door.
I feel like it's mostly a party for cars.
More than it's a party for people.
A party for cars.
What could go wrong?
I don't think I've ever
seen anything like this.
I don't know how to describe
how many people are up
in these hills with these
cars still driving through
with now fire coming out of them.
How are you feeling?
There's a lot of testosterone in here.
Oh, look out, look out, look out.
now dude, Jesus.
Oh, .
Moments later, windows were smashed
and the reckless driver found himself
on the wrong end of an angry mob.
It's the kind of scene
that makes you think this
event might not be around forever.
It's grown so much.
I mean how much more can it grow
before California says get
out of our state, you know.
Pretty dark here now.
What?
Just breaking these windows over there
getting him out the car,
breaking his window.
It's just gotten so crazy that,
you get outside that
gate, and it's dangerous.
People are walking around
out there and you know
drunks wrecking stuff
and wrecking into people.
Well 'cause you kind of feel
like you're at Disneyland
or it's like a it's
not, it's not real life, you know?
'cause it's just strange.
It's hard to control it.
There's just too many people.
I don't see it getting any
smaller that's for sure.
It's going, it's going to blow up
until someone says we're done.
Get out of here.
Welcome to King of the Hammers.
It is the big day.
We've been watching races all week long.
Motos, Desert Challenge and here we are at
the Race of Kings.
I know, you got to share.
It's race morning.
All the drivers are lining up.
My heart is kind of pulling
for the Campbells today.
The family's mechanical woes continue.
Bailey's attempts to fix
her car were unsuccessful.
Her brother Wayland, also
saddled with vehicle issues
They've decided to share
a car and each take a lap.
Bailey will be the first woman to drive
in this race with without a co-driver.
I'm not going to lie,
I'm a little nervous.
Yeah. 'cause I've never navigated myself.
What's your strategy for today?
Try not to get dirt in my eyes.
Alright, well best of luck.
Thank you.
Over in his camp, Jason seems
ready for the long haul.
Got up at the crack of three.
Yeah,
that was it.
I tried to go back to bed but I couldn't.
I was like, ah.
Long day today.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know it'll only
be seven or eight hours
but, it'll be fine.
Yeah.
Just before the race.
We got a moment with last year's winner.
Raul Gomez.
Is it extra pressure when you're the king?
Aah, a little bit.
Yeah?
But not bad.
Yeah, alright man, good luck.
Peace, Man.
♪ And the home of the brave ♪
Hey, are you guys ready
to have some fun out here?
Are you ready for some
awesome Ford racing?
Hit it!
The racers are off,
the grueling hours long battle has begun.
Top speed across flat, dusty desert.
Slowed to a crawl
across the impossibly large rocks.
First lap, complete.
For Bailey, the race is over.
Good job, Bailey.
You passed a whole bunch of cars.
That was so much fun.
So there's only, let me look it up.
Good job, honey.
Whoo-hoo.
Was it short right?
I think you beat your dad on lap one.
No way.
Yeah
On the course two clear leaders emerge,
Jason Scherer and Raul Gomez. Oh
Come on bro.
C'mon baby.
C'mon, keep going, keep going.
Keep goin' baby.
This is kind of the end of lap two.
Jason and Raul Gomez are
the first two in to pit.
They're still neck and neck.
Jason's had some better luck with his car.
Maybe some better driving.
Jason, you know, looks
like he could take this thing
if he keeps going the same way.
Drive smart, brother.
So very, very difficult position
for Jason Scherer to be in
after a long day of racing.
Yes, an even more difficult position
when you know that Raul Gomez
is breathing down your neck.
And you know that he has a one minute
time advantage on you.
How, how close is it?
It's a nail biter, that's for sure.
I don't like nail biters.
Sweeper here just a moment.
Oh yeah.
Raul Gomez in second.
Only 20 seconds behind.
It is tight, tight.
It's going to come down
to seconds, not minutes
At the Gomez family pit,
cautious optimism.
Look at this!
King, around Gomez
He comes in now to take
the Checkered Flag,
Spills into celebration.
Just crazy that such a
long race can come down
to like such a tight window
and feel bad for Jason's team.
Everyone's a little forlorn over there.
Feel good for the Gomez brothers,
the king is the king again.
I'm trying to catch you
all day, brother. Woo.
I'm trying to get away from you all day.
I saw you dead and I'm
like, I got him now.
Oh, .
Proud of you.
Out of about 200 competitors,
only 25 finished.
Shannon came in hours later.
Me, I went home away
from the desert and dust,
wondering exactly what I just witnessed.
It was a preview of the apocalypse.
But with sponsors and people who aren't
at least intentionally trying to kill you.
Felt a little bit like an
outdoor Vegas, felt a little bit
like a January 6th on wheels.
It was an incredibly loud tech conference.
It was California with its
open land and car culture
and startup mindset trying
to fix impossible problems.
It was America.
I almost died, and I want to go back.